Can I take a question from one of the private Facebook groups where I do various
experiments.
And this question is from Christian B while reading and living
stoicism,
how do you avoid spending too much time thinking about the inevitability of
death and how do you harness it to empower you rather than scare or overwhelm
you? So let's begin with a definition of terms,
stoicism or stoic philosophy, very simply.
And this is going to be simplified for any academics out there who want to poke
holes in it is a philosophical system that
focuses on separating the things you can control from the things you cannot
control and then instills in your daily practice
habits and exercises such that you can focus
as much of your energy as possible on things you can control.
Part of stoicism is meditating on
death,
certain inevitabilities and finding freedom in that instead
of overwhelmed. All right, that sounds very nice and theoretical and conceptual.
What does that mean in practice?
I spend an amount of time that might seem ridiculous
reminding myself of death, and this sounds morbid,
but it is very valuable to me because
it emphasizes the
impermanence and the short duration of life
that we have,
which gives me a sense of urgency to pursue the things that are important.
Gives me a sense of urgency in having the
uncomfortable conversations that are so important in life that can
define the next chapters of your life that can change your life.
And without a sense of urgency,
when you sort of cover your eyes and ears to
not think about death, it is easy to push things off to tomorrow, to tomorrow,
to tomorrow until you die.
And it's too late and you would have benefited from asking those uncomfortable
questions, taking those uncomfortable actions far sooner.
So I have, for instance,
a memento Mori coin made by a friend of mine and author Ryan holiday,
well known for his writing on stoicism, which acts as a visual reminder,
I have different quotes that are laser etched onto driftwood that also serve
this purpose. And for that reason, Christian,
I,
I don't try to avoid spending too much time thinking about the inevitability of
death and the way that at least I find it empowering instead
of overwhelming,
is to recognize a it's outside of your control B.
It happens to everyone and see,
you can control in a sense or hone your perception of
death and view it as a catalyzing help, as opposed to,
uh, an overwhelming sadness and practice that
might seem unusual that I have found very valuable and this
hearkens back to an anecdote,
or maybe an allegory of sorts that I was told by Tara Brock,
famous meditation teacher. And that is a famous Sage once said,
the only question worth asking is what are you unwilling to feel?
So as you, you think about death and how you relate to death,
you may also think about how you relate to other emotions.
You don't want to feel for me,
particularly with a history of depression up until say five years ago,
where I have not had any major depressive episodes in the last five years.
And then I think in part,
what I'm going to describe has been very helpful for staving off depression.
I optimized for positive, positive, positive, positive meaning.
I wanted as many moments in my day to be purely positive as
possible. I did not want to feel sad. I did not want to feel tired.
I did not want to feel angry, so on and so forth.
Those emotions are going to surface.
And when you have labeled them as bad and try to
refuse them with as much mental willpower and
emotional willpower as possible, what you resist tends to persist,
and those things have an outsized impact on your life. Negative impact.
Conversely,
if you use here's the practice say minor key music,
which I had not used until a few years ago,
didn't listen to minor key music and just look up minor,
key piano music to get a taste for what this sounds like.
It instills melancholy. It has a sad sound to it. And I've,
I've begun listening to music that evokes that type of
feeling deliberately because at the end of listening to this
music for say five to 10 minutes,
and then you play another track that has a more upbeat feeling to it,
say a lot of Boston Nova from Brazil,
you realize that the sadness much like mint is
transient and that your psyche is poorest in that sense,
the excitement flows, right? And then it flows out of you, not literally,
but of course that is the subjective experience. And that's also true sadness,
which a lot of us try to avoid.
And when you realize how transient that is and how you can turn it on and turn
it off with cues in your environment, it becomes less intimidating.
It becomes less overwhelming. You can use films in the same way,
watching films that are scary, sad, depressive,
whatever it might be.
And then contrasting that with something that is on the opposite end of the
spectrum, that is a practice. In other words,
seeking out artistic cues,
that catalyze emotions,
historically you've tried to avoid that transcends the practice
itself and helps you to relate differently to things like death,
because most likely what you fear or what you find
abhorrent is not so much death itself,
but the way that you're emotionally relating to the concept
or definition of death. I know that sounds very, very abstract,
but that is one way that I've approached this in controlled legal
settings.
I will also say that transcendent psychedelic experiences can
greatly remove if you're of death. Uh,
I think that relates to some of the phenomenology,
AKA subjective reports of a feeling
of fusing with source consciousness,
but we're going to get off into crazy town talk real fast.
If we continue with discussing that particular aspect of my own
personal journey, nonetheless, in a legal, safe,
supervised settings, that is also a tool in the toolkit.
It can be an overused tool in the toolkit, but nonetheless,
it is one tool. Similarly, uh,
there are questions you can ask that I think
show you or showcase the value of keeping death in
mind, such as, uh,
one question and I'm going to paraphrase this. This is from Munib Ali,
who was in tribal mentors.
And I believe the question I asked him was what do you do when you feel
scattered or overwhelmed and his response and Mooney of,
I apologize if I'm not getting this completely right, but it's paraphrased.
And I do use this a lot when you are experiencing something simple,
laying in a warm bed. Uh,
an example that comes to mind for me is laying in a hammock, watching my dog,
Molly, play with a stick. When you are on your deathbed,
how much would you pay or even 20 years from now,
how much would you pay to relive this experience right now?
And very often that number gets quite high.
Maybe it's something that you physically might not be able to do 30 years from
now, 40 years from now,
I was just skiing a few days ago and had a wonderful experience with two of my
closest friends.
What would I pay 40 years from now to have that day
back and experience that and think about it.
Don't throw away that question and make up a
number, really think about what you might spend.
And I think that highlights the value of experience
relative to this decay that we all experienced past a certain point
on our descent to death.
And those are a few of the ways that I try to harness
mortality to empower and enrich wildlife as
opposed to disabling or distracting,
if that makes sense. So those are a few tips,
a few recommendations that have been deeply helpful to me.
And if you'd like to learn more about stoicism,
then I would suggest you Google Tao of Seneca,
Tao of Seneca,
Seneca being one of the foremost writers or best known writers as it relates to
stoke philosophy.
I put together three large PDFs that are available for free with original
artwork and all sorts of fun stuff that dig deeper into the practical
applications of stoke philosophy.